Now before we jump in to creating our landscape material,
I wanna quickly talk about the landscape material slope.
Now in this example here,
we have taken a landscape material and broken it down
to it's just basic components
so that we can highlight what is going on.
And the landscape slope function works like this.
When the slope or the angle of the terrain
is between zero and 0.5 degrees,
we're gonna show grass and then as we start to hit
that 0.5, we're gonna slowly start to fade into dirt.
And we can see that right here,
we have grass and then it's fading into dirt.
Now as that dirt angle goes from 0.5 all the way to one,
we're then going to go from dirt into rock.
And the coolest thing about this is again,
as we lay out our terrain or we raise it
or we lower it or we add features,
instead of having to go in and repaint stuff,
the material takes care of this for us automatically.
And this is a huge time saver
because it allows us to spend more time
manipulating the terrain and less time
worrying about going back in and fixing things
once we've done those manipulations.